engagé dans une véritable course contre
la montre ces résidents préparent le
plus de sacs de sable que possible afin
de protéger leurs propriétés
quincaillerie ont été prises d'assaut
mais tout le monde n'a pas le même
empressement ce couple s'est préparé au
pire il attend Yann sur la plage
sa trajectoire préoccupe les autorités
Yann continue sa route vers la côte
ouest de la Floride après avoir frappé
Cuba son passage dans les eaux chaudes
du Golfe du Mexique pourrait faire de
lui un ouragan majeur de catégorie 4 sur
une échelle de 5 quelques 2,5 millions
de personnes ont reçu l'ordre d'évacuer
c'est le cas de Marie-Claude Tremblay
mon mari et moi on a toute sécurisé
tout ce qui traîne par terre ou qui
pourrait voler au vent ben alors on les
a rentrés en dan dans le garage ça a
pris plusieurs
je sais pas si vous voyez mais en tout
cas on est en train d'élapine peut pour
faire place à la pluie qui a déjà
commencé une fois qu'on a tout fait mal
alors on fait nos valises on s'en va
après
le gouverneur de sainteté ça a réitéré
ce message à ceux qui défilent
d'évacuation
des abris sont mises en place quelques
5000 soldats de la garde nationale de
l'État de la Floride sont déployés le
mot d'ordre et la sécurité car les biens
matériels se remplacent mais pas les
vies ici Mélissa François Radio-Canada
Montréal